Hello y'all. My name is Pedro. I'm the
co-founder of Manufact. And uh today I
want to talk to you about MCP apps.
Specifically, we're going to talk about
the primitives. So, how these apps are
built, how they work, and what they
allow you. How to distribute MCP apps.
So, what is behind the discovery
mechanisms
of MCP servers and apps in general. And
uh why I think you should care about
this because this is how all software
will be used.
So, I'm sure most people here listening
to this talk know what an MCP is.
MCP has been around for quite some time
since 2024.
For a full year, it was a
it became very uh say frequent talk
amongst developers and companies that
were rushing to build these MCP servers.
MCP apps are less familiar concept.
They've been around also for some quite
some time uh more or less uh
since the uh the end of 2025.
But when I talk to companies and people
in general, I see that many people don't
understand what they are and don't
understand they can build them. And uh
specifically, they don't know how to
distribute them.
MCP apps, but also they don't know the
new way to distribute MCP servers as
well.
So, I hope by the end of this talk you
going to know about this and you're
going to be ready to build your first or
iterate on your MCP uh server and app
and you're going to be able to share it
with the world in a more efficient way
brings you more customers and more
users.
A little words about me and the Manufact
uh my company. Uh we build open source
SDKs and the tools for MCP and MCP cloud
uh of the Manufact.
Open source SDKs uh by the name of MCPUs
uh allow developers to build servers
um
>> [clears throat]
>> clients and agents in an easier way. So,
we provide an abstraction over the
official SDKs that allows developers to
ship faster without worrying about how
the spec works beneath.
We have 8 million plus downloads across
our SDKs, and we have 10K stars on
GitHub.
Also open source, uh
the
other product is the inspector. Uh it's
an open source inspector, again, uh
something comparable to the official
inspector from the model context
protocol maintainers
that allows you to test these MCP
servers and apps specifically uh on your
local machine.
Once you build, once you test it,
we have built the cloud for you to ship.
The Manifold Cloud is a cloud vertical
for MCP. We provide all the primitives
for you to be able to ship MCP servers
from your GitHub repo and test them
immediately, share them with your team,
run emails, run publishing checks to
make sure that your app is ready to be
put uh submitted, and many other
features that are
completely specific to MCP.
Of course, we really believe in MCP.
So, let's look uh a bit in the history
of MCP and how did we get there.
So, MCP was launched in 2024, and by the
end of uh May 2025, Idel Solomon, the
other co-founder, started working on
MCPUI, which is this way to kind of MCP
servers that return UI components.
Then, uh
this was like many many people started
talking about MCPUI because this is like
such a great opportunity to ship UI with
your MCP servers to agents. So,
it is interactive experiences where the
agent is calling tools, but it's showing
UIs to the user.
This created a lot of movement. Many
people enjoyed uh this proposal, and the
ChatGPT at some point released the app
SDK,
which is a way to create these
interactive
MCP apps. So, basically MCP servers also
return UI elements.
Also, at the end of 2025, quite
silently, both Character AI and Cloud
released and opened their stores for
MCP.
These stores allow you to submit your
MCP server
and have [clears throat] a one-click
install experience for your users.
For the most time, these stores were
closed in such that were
um
designed and
only allowed for design partners.
But things have changed, and I'm happy
to talk about this later.
In January 2026,
MCP UI
I say converted to MCP apps. MCP apps is
now the official extension of the Model
Context Protocol that allows to return
UI elements within MCP servers.
So this timeline is kind of an
explanation of how the protocol evolved.
And I think still I think two major
things happened in this timeline.
First, MCP apps.
MCP servers are not only returning JSON.
And that allows much richer experiences.
And the second thing, maybe even bigger,
is that the stores opened. This was a
great uh a huge move by the model
providers
probably OpenAI, Perplexity, and
basically every LLM client out there
to say, "Oh, MCP is the way
and we [clears throat] want to have a
way for people to publish vetted and
quality MCP servers so that people can
use them with a one-click install
experience."
This is the situation right now with the
stores.
The uh
that are now being submitted to
Character AI and Cloud
apps for Character AI and connectors for
Cloud
increasingly being accepted. As I was
saying in the beginning, this was uh
each one of them was gated behind design
partnership because the ecosystem was
very young, but now it's a GPT and
called are both accepting more and more
apps.
So, this is a uh
this is the moment to publish yours.
So, let's see what MCP apps actually are
and what you can do with them.
So, an MCP app works in the in the
following way. Uh much of this is very
similar to MCP. The model
is a
in the host owns the tools.
The tools are in a MCP server. But, the
MCP server in this case doesn't return
a JSON string again, but it returns a
widget in a sandboxed iframe.
So, the experience you see is your model
is a streaming text. At some point, it
decides to make a tool call, but the
tool call is not just returning JSON, it
returns a UI just underneath. And this
UI is a sandboxed iframe, so you can as
a company developing these apps, you can
put almost whatever you want.
But, it doesn't end there.
Actually, there is a bidirectional
communication that happens between the
iframe and the host application. So,
from the iframe, from the MCP app UI
elements, you can send messages back to
the host. You can interact in several
ways. I'm going to talk uh more about
that uh later.
The way this works is that MCP uh
declares UI resources
at initialization time.
When the model calls the tool and it
populates the arguments of the tool,
uh the tool can then populate the
arguments of the UI resource, and that
can be then displayed and rendered by
the client.
As you see here, this is the kind of
experience that you can see in an MCP
app.
The MCP server returns tool returns uh
UI resource that is populated with the
tool arguments.
And here you see. So, without UI you
would see like a wall of text. The UI
allows you to organize the information
in a more human readable way.
So, this is uh is a like the basics of
MCP ops. Uh I think they're many many
times uh they've been talked about.
And today I wanted to show a bit more of
what you can do because this is not
often mentioned and I think it's very
interesting to design new experiences
which this new protocol allow.
So, first of all, again, the UI is
displayed in the chat and it exposes a
communication channel
between the UI element and the host
application. So, the host application
will listen for these messages going
through these channels and will react
accordingly.
So, this is the first primitive that I'm
going to talk about. So, model context.
In the UI you can show whatever
information you want. For instance, in
this case we're showing three articles,
but the model doesn't really know it
doesn't really cannot really uh
introspect in real time what is going on
in the UI.
But the protocol
mandates this state uh or this set state
primitive where you can update the state
of the model with respect to the UI
components. So, from the widget itself
you can call this is an MCP use syntax
that makes this a bit easier, the set
state primitive,
and you can update what the model knows
about what's being displayed. So, here
we have a little demo that shows this.
Of course, uh the the the message uh
prompts the tool
and the tool shows the UI.
The state uh of the of this UI element
is that nothing is selected and the
model knows about this.
But if you
modify the UI state, you can
communicate this state change into the
model itself. So, then basically, if for
example, here I send another message,
the model will be aware of what happened
in the UI element.
And you can do this by simply setting
this
using this uh
um this primitive set state and update
the state that the model knows about.
UI message. So, this is another very
cool feature
where from the UI element the UI widget
that your tool returns, you can send
messages back to the model.
So, not only the interaction is I am a
user, I have my chat interface, I see
the UI, and I want to send another
message. Or maybe there is some
contextual message that you can you want
to send. For instance, here we have the
same shoe example, and you might want to
learn more about Trey Blazer Pro.
And uh you can
of course link the click of this button
learn more to the primitive send
follow-up message, and this will send a
message to the chat itself, and the
model can start giving you more
information about the Trey Blazer Pro
shoe in this case.
Um clients have different behavior
regarding this, and this is true for
many of the MCP features.
For instance, Cloud will display the
message in the chat input
and tell the user like the user has the
choice to send it or not.
While OpenAI is a bit more integrated in
this sense, it directly sends the model
the message to the model
and uh and starts streaming immediately
the answer to that message.
This is a very cool feature. Uh so,
again, we have the tool, uh and uh we
have a UI element that's populated from
the tool itself, right?
If the model streams the input tokens
into the tool arguments, you can uh in
live
take those partial input
and update the UI incrementally.
So, as you see in this case, we see that
the
the the the tool inputs are being
populated uh dynamically or gradually,
and the
the UI reacts accordingly. I have a very
cool demo about this just later in a
video where in one of the coolest demos
of MCP apps uh
in the uses exactly this pattern.
So, you can, for example, imagine like
uh you could have a UI component that
renders something like an SVG, and there
is MCP uh MCP apps doing that.
We also seen uh we actually created a
Remotion MCP app where uh we use
Remotion to create a video with React,
and uh we render the Remotion video
inside the widget in real time as the
tokens are streaming in.
Another thing you can do is from the
from the widget itself, you can call
other tools.
So, first of all, you can call the tool,
of course, uh in the
in the
in the tool that was originally called
to gather other data, but from the UI,
for example, you can have a button that
triggers another tool call to gather
additional data about what
what is there in the MCP server.
Again, the primitive is very simple.
This is code on the left here is always
um from MCP use.
This is another very interesting thing
that you can do with MCP apps.
So, sometimes uh what happens is uh for
instance, you uh want your MCP server to
return certain informations,
but you want to um
not show the full information because
maybe is uh
there's private information that you
don't want to give to the to the model
providers,
and therefore, [clears throat] you might
want to redact that
right? This is like a known privacy
issue with MCP servers that you don't
want to return and put into the uh
>> [clears throat]
>> your private information. And MCP uh
also allow you to do that. So, when you
call a tool,
you return a widget, which is populated
with some arguments. You can return
other
outputs as well. As in normal MCP
servers, the the return of a of an MCP
tool is
list of outputs of different types. You
can imagine in this case, there is a
structured output, which is sent into
the widget itself. And there is an
additional output that can be sent
directly to the model. So, something
common that you do is you show a very
rich UI, like in this case, and uh
and this is what the [clears throat] UI
will show. So, this is a card showing
the information private information of
of this person, but the model
will only see the information you want.
So, there's two types of output, the
ones that are shown in the UI, to put it
simply, and the ones that are sent to
the model.
Like a common to maybe understand this
better, a common pattern that you see is
you show the full information in the UI,
and then you instruct the model with a
text output of what the user is seeing.
For instance,
we return a uh this this UI card, and we
can even return
um nothing to the model.
But just say, the user is seeing his
private information in the widget above.
So, this is a pattern that allows you
to, you know, give uh allow it like uh
experiences in in fields where maybe
sharing data to the LLM is not possible
because of privacy issues. In this case,
you can show the UI to the user, but the
model won't see the data that you
display in the UI, unless you choose so.
There's uh another set of
functionalities which I think are minor
or let's say less
>> [clears throat]
>> intuitive or less advanced. Uh
Here we show the request display mode
which basically your MCP app widget
is displayed in uh
in line with the tool call.
But it can even put the full screen. So
the full chat is going to be
your MCP widget
and uh input box is going to be overlaid
on top of the widget. And for instance,
this is very cool for video editing. You
can imagine a a widget showing some uh
graphical interface and uh you can chat
that we improve the the what's the shown
inside the widget and the model can
directly stream into the widget you're
looking at.
It can also be put in a
picture-in-picture or in line which is
the normal case.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> there's a
other primitives that allow you to open
external links from the MCP widget
itself.
>> [clears throat]
>> You can listen to the theme of the OS so
that you know your MCP app is
synchronized in theme with the host your
users are using.
And there are many other things.
So I wanted to show you here a few
videos of MCP apps because so far I've
just been showing uh uh
uh some mock-up that I created for this
presentation. Uh but this is for example
in Cursor we're using the MCP app. Uh
Cursor is one of the clients uh that
supports MCP apps. And as you see here
uh our MCP app returns the analytics of
the remote MCP server app that I was uh
talking to you about just before. And
for instance, this is very uh useful in
in analytics. Uh for instance, we use
Pulsar MCP a lot and then the Pulsar MCP
will show you a UI element with your
with your analytics.
So that you as a human can understand
what's going on, but the model itself
can read those analytics and go do its
job on the code you're you're writing.
Um
on Claude,
so this is the demo I was telling you
about. So, here we're using the
Excalidraw MCP server, and here you will
see the streaming functionality that I
that I mentioned as before.
So,
you can see here that Claude is first
reading the
some instructions that are returned as
tool by the Excalidraw MCP server. And
uh at some point it will call the tool
which is showing the canvas, and it will
stream tokens into the canvas, and I
think we motion it's one of the coolest
animation around how those tokens are
shown.
As you see here, this is like a mermaid
syntax that is sent into the tool, and
the the UI updates as the tokens are
streamed in.
There's some of the some of the coolest
demos here. By the way, very very useful
to draw diagrams as well.
Um and this is again ChatGPT um
uh using the Manifold uh MCP app uh
showing the same analytics that I was
telling you above.
And as you see here, the rendering is uh
is is a bit better in ChatGPT uh
it's better.
Basically, this is very similar to how
it uses.
Maybe uh this is a good time to talk
about the client support. There's many
clients that support MCP app. Some do
more, some do less uh and uh
these three I think are the main uh that
people are using.
And uh of of course, all the different
versions of Claude and ChatGPT uh so
both
Claude Co-work,
Claude Desktop support MCP app, ChatGPT
and Codex support MCP app. Uh and Cursor
uh both in the
>> [clears throat]
>> agent mode and in the normal side chat
supports MCP app, but there is uh many
more that support MCP app such as VS
code and and and comes as others.
And I think it's actually interesting to
to mention here uh that another thing
you can do you might be developing your
MC server and uh you don't know if the
host where your users are using the MC
server supports or not MC
[clears throat] apps.
What you can do is uh since
we know what the client is from the
metadata that is exchanged uh
uh the MC app
uh you can um return a UI element only
for those um host that actually accepts
and can render those um
those uh widgets.
And then this is not really a big deal
because most uh non-MC app clients so uh
MC client that don't support MC app will
not will simply not show the widget. But
I found developing these servers many
times that if you don't show the widget,
you need to return a different output
because um
it
some of the information was returning
the widget but maybe you want to give it
to the model if the widget is not shown.
Uh so this is something also MC user
helps you with with some primitives that
um
that allow you to to know if the client
uh your MC server is connected to
actually supports MC apps or not.
Again, um
a little
uh idea of how you can build these MC
apps with MC users. We are one of the
most popular SDKs to build these uh MC
apps. The way we design our SDKs that
basically you design your MC server uh
as you always did. So you have your MC
server constructor and then you define
tools.
And from the tools, you can simply
return widgets
which are automatically registered from
this widget file in the resources
folder. So whatever you put as a widget
file in the resources folder will be
registered as a UI resource that you can
return from a tool.
And the widget um
the widget file is just a React uh
component uh and you can also use your
existing uh UI components.
And uh it will be compiled
into HTML and CSS.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then um returned and linked it to
the tool.
We have a scale uh
we have a template. Uh you can just run
NPX create MCP app and uh it will give
you a template that you can serve.
So, let's talk about distribution and
discovery, which I think uh it's uh of
course a very important topic. Uh maybe
uh even less known than how MCP apps
work. I'm talking to many people and
they don't know there's a store for MCP
and they don't know how to submit, so
I wanted to talk about a bit about this
as well.
So, the store is like a huge new
distribution channels. Again, you're um
bringing the three most popular clients,
ChatGPT, Claude, and Cursor,
which
the three of them, they all support a
self-serve submission process.
ChatGPT was one of the first supporting
this. Claude, uh since a couple weeks
they have um self-serve submission form
for team and enterprise uh
accounts. [clears throat]
And also Cursor
allows you to submit their MCP server
set uh
The way you submit is different for all
three, but basically what happens is
that you need to make sure that your MCP
app is compliant. MCP apps or servers
can be both uh submitted in all these
three stores, so you it doesn't need to
return a UI your your server to be
eligible for submission.
Um and the three processes to get your
app submitted is different and they have
different speed. So, it's going to take
maybe a bit more on on Claude uh for now
uh and uh ChatGPT instead is it's up a
lot the acceptance of these uh of these
apps.
And
again, the process is you link your
remote MCP server.
They will scan the tool. And they will
make sure that all the tools are
correctly annotated.
And have the correct arguments and
um
And once this is done, they're going to
scan the the authentication as well. So,
if your server requires authentication,
you have to declare it and you need to
make sure that it works.
There's a few more different steps which
are details for all the all the
providers.
Uh but it's important to say that once
your app is submitted, it's going to be
partially manually or partially
automatically tested. So, you will have
to provide some test cases and some test
prompts. And then
it will be either accepted or rejected.
And
if accepted, you're going to be able to
publish it and make it available on the
stores that you can find on
chadigpt.com/apps
on the connectors directory on
uh cloud or on the
>> [clears throat]
>> the cursor directory.
Again, we we we did the many submissions
and we we try to make this process
easier. So, if you want to submit your
app, I think you should go to
manifester.com where we vet your app to
make sure that it's um
ready to be submitted. So, we check and
we try to do all the checks that those
clients will do in the submission
process. And also, we run
we generate some of the submission
artifacts that you need to submit like
screenshots and test cases for you in in
our cloud directory if connected to your
MCP server.
Something very very cool about this is
that once your app is in the store, not
only can people find it by searching on
the store, not only
>> [clears throat]
>> you can send a URL to your customers and
they're going to be able to install your
application in one click. So, you don't
have to share that ugly JSON file
anymore with your MCP configuration.
But it's very important that dynamic
discovery of MCP server is happening.
Today Cloud is the only client that
actually does this, but for all apps in
the stores, when Cloud needs is like
assigned a task that doesn't have a
specific tool to do,
it will actually search in the MCP
registry for the right connector to do
the task.
So imagine what this means for your
particular product. All the people
There's many of course active users on
those applications or more than billion
active users,
which will manifest an intent directly
in the chat and through the intelligence
of the model, the model will choose what
is the best connector.
And if you're there,
and you do your work to be the connector
that is selected,
this is going to be like a a huge wave
of uh
high intent individuals
that want to need your product and will
find it uh
dynamically and organically on those on
those platforms.
So this is very important.
Cloud does this today
and [clears throat] ChatGPT is expected
to do this pretty soon.
So that was my discrete descriptive part
of the talk.
I just want to uh
uh
I think it should be
clear by now how important it is to be
on the stores.
I can bring my experience. Being on the
store brought us a lot of traffic.
Personally, as a user of MCP,
today I'm checking if a product has an
MCP server and that's for me is like the
most basic buying decision.
I run most of my day-to-day work on
Cloud Co-work or Cloud Code because I
love the the the possibility to share
the context between my code base and my
different connectors. And this to me is
so important. For instance, one workflow
that I that I often run is I have my
Granola MCP where I have my meeting
notes. I have Linear where I track my
tickets. Of course, I'm in my code base
if I'm using this from Cloud Code. And I
can basically pull the meeting notes
with some customer feedback and feed it
back in the in Linear maybe I create
tickets for the rest of the team. And
then I have the agent that pulls the
Linear ticket through the Linear MCP and
just starts doing it. Opens the PR.
And uh
and uh and closes the Linear ticket. And
uh I mean, in an ideal world, it would
even send an email back through MCP to
the customer saying, "Oh, this is
fixed." But
maybe we're not there yet. Um
but uh but this is definitely true. And
in fact, just a few days ago, Paul
Graham, uh the founder of Y Combinator,
said, "Uh AI apps are the new browsers."
And in this case, uh the AI apps are
Cloud Code, Codex, Cloud Code Work. And
I fully agree with this.
If you think about it, Google Search in
a way has been
substituted by looking on ChatGPT.
So, now that we have connectors where
you cannot only search, but you can also
do stuff in the real world,
>> [clears throat]
>> all those all those um operations are
going to be moved to the chat as well.
So, in a way, I think uh that if AI apps
are the new browsers, the ChatGPTs are
the new websites. And uh as a website,
they can return a UI with MCP apps.
So, again, uh I don't want to look at
your dashboard anymore. I want to use it
in Cloud.
And if any dashboard, I want to see it
in the Cloud Code application. So, ship
an MCP app. Thank you very much. I hope
you enjoyed the talk and I'm uh hope
there is any questions about this and
super happy to help.
Um by now, have
a very uh expert on the topic.
So, thank you very much. Have a good
one.